supposons j'ai une tique fixé sur la
main on engage le crochet latéralement à
la tic puisque la tika est très plate
latéralement donc on engage latéralement
par rapport au corps de l'attique et on
exerce une rotation cet objet fait
désormais partie de l'équipement de
nombreux randonneurs le crochet tire
tique
il a été inventé en 1994 par un
vétérinaire à oyonnax il trouvait que
les pins ce n'était pas assez efficace
pour enlever les tic des chiens c'est
pas cette avait quand même la fâcheuse
habitude de comprimer le corps de
l'attique et l'éthique
comme vous savez transmettre des agents
infectieux des virus des bactéries dont
la maladie de lyme quitterait fait
parler d'elle en ce moment donc j'ai
fait ce petit clou que j'avais recourbé
greffant du et donc je l'utilisais comme
ça et je retire et medic par rotation le
vétérinaire a breveté est commercialisé
son invention
d'abord pour les animaux puis pour les
humains aujourd'hui l'entreprise
jurassienne devons plus de 2 millions de
crochet par an partout en europe et aux
états unis
et l'activité continue de se développer
on pensait vraiment que ça allait rester
un produit vétérinaire et pour l'animal
de compagnie et on a été
à vrai dire un petit peu surpris de
partir sur le marché humain et c'est une
opportunité pour nous c'est un nouveau
marché et c'est un fort potentiel sur ce
marché les tirs tic sont fabriqués à
oyonnax chez un sous traitant spécialisé
dans l'injection de petites pièces en
plastique les crochets pèse entre 2 et 4
g et l'angle de la fourche est très
précis il doit permettre de retirer les
tic les plus fines donc une tique qui
viennent se fixer mais elle est vraiment
plate comme une petite feuille de papier
vraiment très très fine et une petite
gorgée et beaucoup plus épaisse et si on
veut avoir l'armé absolue à dire il faut
qu'on connaîtra stream ans que nos
instruments s'adapte à toutes les
morphologies
l'entreprise est le plus gros fabricant
de tir tic au monde
elle continue d'essayer d'améliorer son
produit pour lutter plus efficacement
encore contre toutes les maladies
transmises par ce petit acarien